the Joe Rogan experience you know it's
like 30 of you just sitting there you
all came from different countries
different here yeah that's so strange
about those hookup spots for some creepy
gay dudes yeah they would find this but
like like yeah they meet in toilets in
like remember there was that one was it
a senator pick up that it was in
Minnesota in Minnesota he was a senator
from Ida and he goes no I was just I was
just topping to see who's there yeah
he's the creepiest guy Craig I think was
his last name he's the one who sit on
when Clinton was in trouble he was like
Clinton has been a very naughty boy dare
I say a nasty boy somebody who says it
like that you know that there's a
selection
dare I say round before the Internet
yeah but they probably had like there he
is Larry Craig wide stance arrest turns
10 wide stance stance
oh my god here's a wide stance to go to
the bathroom so he was putting his feet
I overreacted and made a poor decision
Craig said of his guilty plea let me be
clear I'm not gay
why guilty then with like yeah it's just
easier re there's a lot easier than the
paperwork he argued that the arresting
officer misconstrued his actions what
are the odds though you try to get an
officer to suck your dick but here's the
thing though like what if a officer is
like one of those cops that sets up
speed traps like what you know what if
yes what if you were not gay and he's
just like yeah I need to make a collar
I'm here looking for four guys to suck
my dick and there's nothing yeah I
haven't had a single bite hard fishing
he's got a [ __ ] stick of dynamite I'm
just a chuck this in the water see what
happened call a senator Wow
yeah well an if you're if you really I
mean it's you really didn't do this oh
yeah definitely or now I'm divider hand
motions
yeah and played footsie an attempt to
arrange a sexual encounter but here's
the thing I'll prove that prove that for
what prove prove that he's trying to
arrange a sexual encounter maybe this
needed toilet paper but they didn't he
just pled guilty cuz he panicked did you
hear about the guy recently they got
busted he was a pastor and he got busted
trying to pay for gay sex with an Arby's
card an Arby's card an Arby's card he
pulled the wrong card to an arc to or to
an undercover officer who's gonna pay
credit yeah he tried he was like on a
sugar daddy site he's like I've had a
lot of sugar daddies my sharp sugar
babies this guy Missouri church leader
huh trying to pay for kinder this is
with an Arby's card re-scribe hey listen
del prostitution prostitutions in the
gay community is a different animal I
think it's much more acceptable don't
even Italy yeah I mean they don't go
[ __ ] yeah it's more it's more rugby
rules as opposed to American football
rules also like isn't it look the need
for the prostitution so much less right
like I feel like yeah why do you got
excuses because old guys they want to
[ __ ] young guys and these young guys
don't want to [ __ ] them but these young
guys don't have a car yeah I don't know
what's up yeah yeah I know how to make
something that Patrice O'Neal story
where he said he pulled over a rest stop
to get some sleep
and somebody knocked on his window a
recipe was like way off like away from
like the where the store was and he's
like what and the guy was like hi he was
like what and the guys like oh my bad
because you're bad what what are you
doing here I think I just turned and ran
away great game guys before they had
these apps and ways to meet up and
wallet it yeah Craigslist they used to
have to have like a little secret spots
well yeah that stops we're always the
secret spot that was a what was the
singer George Mike
thing right it was like a party in
Beverly Hills right yeah but you know
you know that [ __ ] had to be bumping in
in [ __ ] 80s going to that Park I'm
sure every gay dude in the city was like
I'll see you in BH man you know remember
with the guy from school shopping at
doors man [ __ ] your day that be if the
day after you found out about that Park
you're like wait that park restroom
wasn't a restroom
the infamous George Michael bathroom I
guess the hell's yeah
but is the bathroom at a park man it's
gotta be [ __ ] rough to be gay and
just try to meet guys are you see easy
well remember the rule was like if you
had like a certain color handkerchief
that meant what you were into oh yeah
and you would have it out of your back
pocket there's a day of Florida State if
you were blue jeans blue just blue jeans
you have connection come now Florida
people just trying to [ __ ] dudes they
should sell more specific than that yeah
that's a mistake waiter what if you
don't get online we all know shirt day
and your [ __ ] shorts are dirty so
I'll just put my blue jeans on today you
know if some guys are trying to [ __ ] you
hey man you know sorry I did everything
else aware it is great Christina went to
University of San Francisco she said in
the 90s though I think it's the Folsom
Street Fair something she was like guys
with fists in the streets yeah yes I got
guys about [ __ ] just up on the wall
[ __ ] the first day in New York I went
out with the editor of Us Magazine and
he took me to a gay bar in the
Meatpacking District and I saw a dude
can't be alive anymore
yes stars tattooed on his butt cheeks
down to his heel like he was a big
Cowboys fan but [ __ ] and I saw him
get [ __ ] in the ass and I was I was
fresh out of Florida State this right on
the street you know in a bar it was in a
bar he got [ __ ] in the ass in a bar at
a bar just on the students laughs and I
was like oh wow dude I was like this I
remember I remember yeah
what if there's some some gay guys that
miss those days
oh yeah yes that are like this was that
was when we were [ __ ] out oh oh
create your own Jeff Scott the piano
player at the Comedy Store talk about
pre-aids
what was that I got a theater troupe
before a then he was like it was our
[ __ ] fast I bet a lot of guys got into
musicals that didn't even like music
where's the spot where do we go
[Applause]